and we are off we have boy boy with the
white pieces against Yasuo and voyboy he
was streaming very late last night and
my bad for that talking about pineapples
and yes all these movies so maybe I've
ruined him it's possible but efore
starts out very natural with the King's
pawn so is this what you showed him or
not we actually didn't go through
openings I was going through tactics and
just train of thought and yourself to
come up with wait what
whoa so do you think come on mo well I
taught in the kuru con I mean come on
dude move one you forget to push the
pawn first dude come on come on mo see
six first move then d5 to fight for the
center instead he plays d5 right away
and wait what wait what so we have an
advanced French kind of but he put the
bond at c6 so he been reverted back to
the car Khan so let's listen to most
thoughts because the we hear why he came
this way sooner than that that's the
place
cars disappointed what you want for me
then okay I'm literally speechless this
is turning into a great opening I shall
walk with this actually it turned into a
Dutch kind of like he wants to go for
stonewalled Dutch and can't explain it
this bishop though I see a I'm not
playing the Karl con so I don't mind
trading as much it was all intentional a
car yeah kind of a kind of kind of
insane this opening start from from yeah
so but he got lucky because boy boy did
not do on for thought and captive upon
an f5 so maybe he just went full five
head yeah maybe yeah maybe it might work
out really nicely for him I thought look
to do something like that look at he
knows he needs to get that fish about
he's using this don't get this keen idea
no idea what I want to do let me think
of my ideas here I can go here to then
maneuver my piece over here but I don't
really see what that does for me too
much it's actually decent move but I
think before I even do that the main
thing is I need to get these pieces out
this doesn't have any ideas I can't go
here because if I go here then off to go
here then I'll have to go here
maybe I just follow it up though and
like do all I can maneuver I like that
so we're gonna do this or probably gonna
rip up and then we're gonna go here or I
could push up to middle but I don't like
Brett to middle I want to keep my rook
on this file so after I look to get a
move here then I can go here boom boom
boom boom boom it's gonna take me time
to maneuver my pieces out but I have
like a nice defense here so I let's see
how he tries to break it
hey man can't reach ah oh I'm gonna
minimize chat okay thanks chess sorry I
had it on mo only so only VIPs and mods
could type so like they're not gonna
cheat but I just minimize chat and I'll
try my hardest regardless
make some music on Wow is he from New
York by any chance um he lives in
California I don't know I don't know
exactly where it's from the reason I ask
is for one his username on just kind was
mellows dad so I didn't know if I got
Carmelo Anthony and also he talks a mile
a minute like maybe his dog is his dog's
name is Melo I believe uh but I I think
he might be from New York I'm actually
not sure he lives in California but I
think he actually might be from New York
got it he does he's from Long Island
okay yeah he's from New York okay yeah
you're right that's actually that makes
a lot of sense that's now speaks really
quickly yeah but his ideas were coming
very quickly and he had many of them and
plenty of them were good like he Bros
Knight to g6 and his Queens on v6
hitting B tune putting pressure on d4
right so I think action at this point he
is better but he needs to push the pawn
to c5 and break the pawn chain this is
very critical at some point that's
that's right because this and this pond
d4 is removed and upon e 5 will feel
some pressure and from roadways point of
view he's certainly not familiar with
his opening I don't see any way he would
be yeah I mean I think certainly boy boy
was surprised by the by the Scandinavian
defense we pushed the pond but really
the thing that boy boy missed was that
he forgot to play on pass on that was
the big mistake right I'll just show
that moment one more time after f5 he
can take it through as if it moved to
one square just in this turn and take
office on opens up the position for his
pieces so instead he did not do that and
let's tune into voyboy to hear how he's
feeling about this position good night
here defend this and this reinforce this
pun to seems kind of good let me try
that
the night back so that night sucking
these two squares it doesn't really have
additional moves you come back here I
think I can start moving on the kingside
so ignite here medias all up and this
point is protected by this night I think
I'm pretty safe to do this should I be a
little careful although I was gonna say
Robert if he played 97 I think 95 is
close to winning it's true so his miss
flick actually works out really well is
now he can push the pawn to e6 and
remove the night from g5 that's right
and what way clearly trying to be
aggressive in this game and with megi
frosting of Queen h5 and go for an
attack
it shouldn't actually amount to like a
checkmating attack but h6 can be a scary
to play that weakens the squares and
erkang think of he wants to be nice if
I'm next gets the opportunity it's right
right so the pod to h6 would be would be
a good move for move tonight much
quieter than a Mesa seeing him when he's
playing chess yeah I mean I think now
that we're in the bracket stage they're
very very serious they realize it's
gonna be much more competitive and so
they're they're really really folksy
five here is an excellent move to avoid
on whether here ever means team that
would be really good I go eight you pawn
down try I think I'm launching the h1
it's also a good strategy
each one down clean cakes try reinforce
attack on the king his pieces are pretty
trapped so this is good for me I could
also improve the position of my rook
once good recognition and then go for
the idea what are his ideas so he might
go for a pawn break here that's the case
good understanding he's thinking about
your home's ideas - I could just take it
yes so far I think I think there's a
grill questions avoid boy how boy boy
handles the time situation this is the
most important thing here that's right
and is down I'm in half on the clock and
Yasuo is known to play quite quickly and
there's no pollen trades this far right
so it goes clean up through which is a
move I really don't like because now you
can play pawn to h6 to kick the knight
back
now whether Voigt whether yeah so it
finds are not remains to be seen but I
do think it's this is a very critical
game super early on or not games are a
critical move super early on so yeah so
has to find pawn to h6 to remove this
night yeah and I think actually this
move it makes sense of course because
you're attacked and I'm kicking it
backwards but also my process of
elimination
this knight on b8 can't move in d7
because you this ecigs pawn will feel
like a problem
well like ends up 96-95 actually works
but that's pretty hard to see like
really hard to see pretty high-level
stuff there yeah you're right that would
be able to be captured and I think just
you think you need your Bishop protect
you so you wanna do that so then you
like oh I want to get rid of the
attacker and then you're more likely to
blame like age 6 mm-hmm exactly yeah and
you play Knight a 6 you know he
developed a knight but he's kind of
walking into Queens 3 but let's listen
to me in here what Yasuo is thinking
because this could be a biggest I'll
retreat to this piece
yeah miss cookie and chats might work
well if I like Matt didn't mean miss
clicking in an actual tournament I swear
I got to flip the board I probably flip
the board that's right in front of me I
start punching it up to put a hole in it
I leaked it open I sign up on two
minutes on time maybe I can slag boy boy
okay maybe I go here just to look at
that tack and then get that paste there
this piece is here because he's trying
to break my defenses how can I stop this
piece from advancing the car he is you
like he is your project maybe I look for
attack now his arrow game is very strong
maybe I move what if I move King up to
put this here and then get my kings to
retreat to the other side of the board
or I could look for here and if he goes
here then I go here and it opens that
back up I like that actually I really
like that because I need to get this
piece in the game so if he moves pawn up
then I go here and if he takes then I
take and if not then he just sits here
and then I'm like King is super defended
by his pawn as well he's actually giving
me a setup to defend quick consistent
moves that e6 pawn
there's notices I have multiple packing
here boom boom
who doesn't know yeah so or boy go here
too and I'll have a double attack
against that but it won't really do
those pong tanks and then that's you
know we're chillin what's showing you
know right now probably now he notice if
I go here what does he want to do he can
go here my pawn structure gets target
where I just moved Paulo no no no then
he just takes back don't you see they
get a free apartment structure if I go
if I do I don't my books under attack -
I see my rook is actually kind of high
if I go here and he takes and I go back
I have to go here I think I want to
retreat my king to the other side of the
board my Kings being heavily under
attack this line sucks now I need to get
this right well we heard his thoughts he
is first recognizing that there's some
attacking chances and then unfortunately
because that Pawnee 6 was protected for
so long that I think you just forgot
that once this bishop moves it lost his
defender right and well now the
positions opening up and oh we can't
hear his thoughts anymore I'm guessing
they're not so happy once you lose that
pawn to e6
probably not but again boy boys been a
little bit slow here and he's got to
find the right checkmate idea like 95
with Queen h3 g3 King g2 is I think
almost a foreshock made here or at the
very least gonna be winning a lot of
material so it's a very strong idea and
look at that with a3 just saying you're
Knights not getting into b4 so that's
one of those that really don't like a3
though it's too timid yeah because now
that rook goes to h7 and now yeah so
starts to see some ideas with checkmates
coming down to open age file and so
voyboy drops his knight back but rook
can go to h5 where it attacks the night
it's protected by very
to keep the rook on this open each file
very very critical um but yeah I'd be
getting a little bit worried here if I'm
if I'm a boy boy because the time
situation is getting a little bit close
oh gee three very nice move very smooth
he recognizes that he needs his rook on
the Aged file so he let um yeah so we
get there first but he said I you only
have one rook there and you're not gonna
be able to connect your works with the
bishop and the King in the win so now I
think c5 is one of the best moves black
is obviously much worse but you want to
try to open up the position if you can
now as long as boy boy goes King tree to
I think he's very much in the driver's
seat and probably gonna win the game but
the time the clocks are starting to tick
down so it's it's still still dicey and
I would be surprised if he didn't play
King g-tube because he played g3
voluntarily six is a good move mm-hmm
but as long as he sees some idea
involving a taking the h5 with the King
move I think he's in he should be doing
pretty well but again it's not it's not
obvious to see and he might just think
okay well the Queen just guards the
square on each one and that's good
enough it's true but he did play g3 by
himself and you're right it does open up
the Queen to protect h1 but it feels
like he's gonna go with these plans
together and well let's listen in to
hear his thoughts especially after like
east six was getting aggressive
- yeah fishing I see it not to be okay
even g4 is pretty good - ever everything
here in Paoli might weaken his stress
from work but there's Queen your minds
but I've been clean Anders Queen c7
that's a really good point
whew well yeah OC Queen c7 27 has moved
it's right up his alley if we go for
meeting ideas here oh boy sorry but I'm
pretty confident to trade Queens here -
I think also if he takes the pawn I have
Queen here checkmate so we have to be
careful for that - I'm sure he'll see
that though you might try like a
desperado Queen here if he does I think
I just go
I came with to run like a king over so
you're pointing out a while back and go
pawn tail right let me get I think the
danger here those after Keaney eight
like what's uh it's not so clear for
white like you can your king can also
become very open here that's true
potentially so it's it's it's it's a
funny like inadvertent blunder and I
think boy boy is much better but it's
hence yeah it's a tricky position of
plagues it is completely winning for
white but it's not it's not clean it's
definitely not something that's that's
straightforward and you get really low
on time there could be blunders by
either player here that's true because
the King on the eighth needs easy
advantage of that and do it quickly
because otherwise Blackwell claiming was
like rook g8 pinning this night or Queen
c7 threatening that shake me in on h2
and the longer this game goes on the
more chances black should have so I
think that boy boy needs to find a good
looking move like even Bishop g4 to wrap
this right I think Bishop g6 might
actually win here but it's a very hard
move to play especially with the
pressure the tight time situation both
players getting slowly getting low on
time he played it way he plays it though
very nice
oh yes he understood that his queen
needed to go through the bishop so he
gets the bishop on the way first-class
and this King can't run away because it
can try to run to c7
but King d89 f7 Kingston I mean f4 is
that's checkmate unfortunately very nice
a very nice play by uh by voyboy here
okay so keen d8 was pleased he tried to
run away with the king but unfortunately
yeah this is uh yeah yeah very about the
game by voyboy though I also see the
meeting 17 that the engine is it's a
seventeen on over here
oh wait that's not double Chuck
nevermind ok so now Queen out four and
now has made one on GG's but if he
doesn't find the checkmate
it takes the
instead yeah there's no way he doesn't
see it yeah I think I think he sees it
he doesn't yeah so it doesn't even see
it boy boy definitely does and he plays
it and I miss click that it put me on
tilt
all right don't even flame don't flame I
miss click then it put me on total ok
what actor she did I play with let me
see how poor that was that's probably
worse the game of chess I've ever played
I want to see that I want to see what it
says guys literally the Miss click put
me on totally ok well he said the miss
click put him on tilt but this this game
here was I mean well pretty well played
by boy but after the opening the opening
did not go his way mo got the a good
position out of it with a surprise but
ultimately I think that boy boy handled
the next stage very well yeah boy boy
played very well in that game a couple
was in the middle were a little bit iffy
but but overall very clean game played
by played by boy boy and he deserve it
winner in the first game yes interesting
this set up because we saw mode choose
this against hutch this sort of
Stonewall type of position but the
problem with it is your queen side
pieces never really gets a breathe life
into your game right exactly yeah so I
think I think in terms of the opening
one thing I thought against hutch it was
a good opening choice but I felt in
general thinking about that that general
setup with the pawns there perhaps it's
not in most IELTS is too much of a
maneuvering kind of game where you have
to figure out where to put the night
where to put the Bishop and so forth and
he tried his best and you know we're
about to see game to start so everybody
stay exactly where you are because this
yeah so as a chance to score point and
even the match but he tried and he
brought his Knight to g6 and then he
brought back to e7 just that's not the
way you want to play these positions
moving the pieces back and forth well as
mo point out he wanted to play Knight to
d7
so the misclick really did did affect
him in a bad way I think after 97 it
still would have been very interesting
um but but nonetheless you keep going
and unfortunately
one move yeah it was too much but I
think in general is just a structure it
doesn't lend itself to most style that's
why I don't like it I think the
structure is very it's closed its
maneuvering it's not open and Moe's a
very sort of player who needs open open
space and needs to be be pushing up the
board but that being said boy boy played
really well and definitely deserve to
win that game found some excellent moves
she threw was a good move and then
finding his Bishop g6 was was just class
absolutely absolutely good moves from
from from from boy boy for sure and now
if we get some black pieces most starts
with E for and well what do you expect
from mo here in the Sicilian I expected
to play Knight up three here well he
wants closest to him which is he's a
player of my own heart I grew up playing
too close too soon and playing it badly
I might say but still I like this
closest iliyan okay no he's going back
okay he just he has the order he has a
different order but okay this is good
okay so 94 yeah I mean mainly what I
want to see is I want to see him play us
play the solid opening that we looked at
and then see what happens but basically
just just played the solid opening
develop the Bishop protection Knight
what somebody how cringe how strong
that's take that night we're good we're
in the games to learn the game I don't
get it he didn't take a knight how do
you explain that oversight agarró I am
so confused I am so so confused but as I
was saying like the pointers maze I
remember I was showing mode this last
night I feel like several people in
chatter like they were like we're sure
mo is gonna blunder like he's gonna
blender something in the opening and
yeah I mean do we know what I mean we
aren't listening to audio but did Boyd
Boyd do that intentionally is that being
its is he being nice I have no idea but
if he is that is that being nicer being
mean how would you assess that I I don't
I don't know okay so of course why
should castle the King here or between
Dee - but I think promote right now he's
just like he just needs to take a deep
deep breath and just chill out because
he's clearly very rattled okay so he
plays Knight b3 not a bad move attacking
the Queen yeah and this position
actually lends itself to most style you
were saying he likes his pieces being
aggressive in an open position but you
have all your pieces developed your
official in c4 is aiming towards the
black king and a move like Queen before
could be annoying but that's a really
hard move to play right I think we
before probably a good move but it is a
very hard move to place you feel like
you're opening up the Queen to attacks
here so yeah high drama high job for
sure in this game oh my gosh I can't
believe that first me yeah sir oh is you
know he's too strong to make a blunder
like that and then from voyboy
not taking it that's fascinating let's
listen - yeah so to hear his thoughts
because I wonder if he's really from
that mistake or he's going to rebound
like like you know at least he like set
the P like pave the way for me you know
you know Spain no no oh my god oh my god
oh no oh no you just dropped his bishop
I don't want to treat Queens coz my
queen is my talking piece
oh no there's that [__] is gone you
know someone get the attitudes of
chestnut bomb appreciated but there's
something glitch somewhere I don't know
what it is but there's a glitch guys
seriously I'm not even kidding I'm not
kidding there's a glitch I swear to God
hikaru I'm sorry yeah sorry you wasted
your time I apologize okay I Paul people
were asking me last night what's the
funniest excuse you've heard people make
when they blunder at lose a game and
being a glitch is top notch so we're no
longer listening the players and Knight
takes e4 just played by boy boy this is
mal crushing yeah but the one thing I
will say is at least here Moe is gonna
get some kind of discovery or attack
like you can trade the Knights and put a
rook on e1 and anything goes kind of but
yeah I uh
yeah hey crazy well the most important
question in cars do you forgive mo he
apologized yeah no I mean I think this
is one issue with mo I've seen it he's
very very talented but he does have this
tendency to move way too quickly where
it's just like he I don't know if it's
confidence or what it is but he like he
likes to move too quickly and not it
doesn't think quite enough so um yeah I
mean it's it's a little bit frustrating
but you know I guess what I would say is
if this was the first game I think for
mo would be a lot worse was the fact he
lost the first game already it's it's
not it's not as sort of as big of a blow
yes it won't be as shocking I guess and
he'd oppose we're gonna he won but let
me ask you then if there were eight
pogchamp bullet tournament would mo be
your favorite um yeah probably he would
be I mean I think he clearly he's one of
the very few players where I think he's
better with less time
more time you have he seems to the
things seem to go wrong more easily but
yeah I just he's moving way too fast now
boy was really just being he's just
really like yeah this is kind of gross
to watch honestly yeah I guess you know
boy boy
you didn't miss the free piece the
second time around now he's taking all
the pieces and no attack normally when
you're down some pieces you want to
attack something some hope but not here
yeah I mean I think the only hope is go
8-4 h 5 and pray any play Bishop g5 ok
decent art and h4 h5 hope that board
messes up mmm doesn't look likely yeah
this is uh yeah can't believe you
apologized to you yeah I mean I
yeah it's I think again I think the
thing is you have to you sort of have to
find the right balance between how much
information you give them and and what
they do with it and I mean perhaps like
the setup I gave us a little bit too
complex maybe but I thought based on
what he told me in terms of like the
percentage of what he thought he had 50
percent chance to win the match I
thought it was a very sharp idea a way
to play
unfortunately confused to move order and
he's paying a very very big price for it
to sign of a good coach so willing to
take the blame even if at that moment he
could have slowed down a second and
realized pieces under attack but I think
you're right though and I've noticed
that when I've worked with some of the
players that when you give them a lot of
information they mean kind of conflate
different positions where that idea
works in one variation but a slight move
order to change and also wait you have
to watch out because your magnen center
isn't under attack twice and so you need
to look to see what your points would
just did and unfortunately for mo he
continued with a natural plan and two
different times let his piece hang right
it's unfortunate certainly but again the
game's not listen to yeah are we
listening to yeah so again let's listen
to yeah sir one here Imran
maybe I have some tactics of bringing my
queen here too late what if I could have
done that last move what if I move my
Queen here lost move to stop him from
ever doing that and then I look for me
if I can kick this piece I should have
done that I think I could have found
them squeeze the victory I resign
for the sake of money get out I'll play
it out I guess but in a normal game I
probably just resign here I'll resign
after the next blunder because hey it's
Coventry he's funny
it looks to do guys mm chin resign
ladies just know nothing I can do you
know I'm down so many pieces
I'm not hitting anything in the middle
this is still just a friendly that pawns
defending that pawn
maybe I take let him take I take this
he's going for the wild tactics no but
that misses hanging why is he he's like
running it down mid what is he doing
doing I think he's already resigned as
an engineer now like catch up one come
on just calm don't be greedy let me use
an engine like can you call Freddy right
exactly yeah
don't be greedy
whatever I wonder boy boys gonna go roof
behavior I take I'm gonna take and then
yeah actually I can't even cuz I'm gonna
be in check
god I dumped so hard this game I'm
cheating resign if he takes us it's it
yeah just gonna yeah just resign man its
new him guys that's like don't even a
game that he was and very entertaining
from yah so I mean it's really
unfortunate because if we just go back
here he had the right set up completely
and he knew that he needs his Bishop on
III and bishop on c4 he just inverted
the move order right exactly yeah yeah
and boy boy doesn't take it and then the
next time around he attacks the Queen
what would makes a great move Queen to
b4 mmm-hmm and then he moves his Queen
to block the pin which was smart but
unfortunately it doesn't work here
because the bishop was lost right yeah
they're very very tough opening opening
for for free yeah so in this game um a
knight b3 probably wasn't the right move
either but again it's sort of a set of
he wasn't familiar with but I think the
fact that he lost the first game
probably played a played a big role in
terms of how he approached this and it
was just difficult difficult game from
from the start for yah so and boy boy is
definitely the deserving winner and he
moves on to the semi-final yeah it's
just like in the match between Nate Hill
and hutch when you make a mistake
against voyboy maybe you can get away
with a little one but the second time
around you're gonna pay the price and
after that first game which was pretty
tense now in the second me down a full
point you probably don't feel so
confident so yeah so it has been quite
strong throughout these pogchamp but he
end up playing the highest rated player
and well unfortunately for him boy boy
was on Form today yeah definitely a lot
of credit goes to boy boy the first game
was very very up-and-down but once he
got through that the second game just
played very very well and and a lot of
credit to him for winning match for sure
we will be right back we will bring the
players on for the post match interview
so stay tuned during this pogchamp not
just like i'm well be returned with the
players both yeah oh and boy boy here
boy boy congrats on
win and Yasuo I mean you played some
interesting chess but unfortunately some
some hoops and go your way yeah it's a
little unfortunate I'll be honest you
know I prepped quite a bit and I've
learned a few openings to start it off
you know no black pieces at a certain
point honestly what I was ready to play
white first not black first so as well
in my own head there and then one of the
black pieces
I've listened what's so hard to me about
chess like to me playing okay as you
guys could tell clearly I don't even
know how to play chess but let me
explain to you me chess like reacting to
people moves as normal and stuff but for
me what's hard is to remember what
opening and what line to play versus
what line and what opening day play so
when he played I forgot even what movie
played I played a some move I forgot one
move I played and I was just moving
quick and I'm a certain point I was like
all right the only way I can avoid out
because I up is through time and then I
end up missed like I move moved by night
forward moving it back lost pure misc
like by the way I got robbed and then I
gained a mode it's not it's chess isn't
chess isn't like playing yah so you
can't just like - through your pawns and
like like outplay you gotta like
actually like yeah yeah but it's cool
it's fun I mean I guess it's sort of
move one right you played d5 and the car
was saying he told you the car con and
it said you push the pawn immediately
miss center so was that just a mistake
or did you prepare that specifically for
boy genius over here hmm no wasn't a
mistake but my brain just wasn't working
if I'm gonna be honest I couldn't I
couldn't remember what the Kirkland
started with and this kind of crunch
started was it with the C pawn that I
push I'm supposed to yes okay yeah I
forgot that part so I I forgot the first
move got to the second move and then it
just like yeah I can't remember opens
it's hard it's hard to remember that
pawn when he was like no I know I agree
with you though when you were talking
about doping is that like I I don't
really know openings either and people
like always make fun of me when I mess
it up but like I don't know it's it's
just like it's like doing homework you
know dude like we're not we're not like
in math class like reading like you know
like some guy with the last name I can't
pronounce his like book on like you know
the 10 best chess openings we're trying
to like play like outsmart each other
like make some like big tactic like
McCain
Moo's on the chess board so I I feel
your pain dude I'm just gonna be honest
you just said a bunch of words and that
made no sense you won the game sir oh
boy
who's making fun you I'll have a word in
this first game it seemed like things
went your way even though you seem off
tilts a little bit boy you didn't know
this d5 move no I'm pretty sure someone
in my like blitz games play against me
but I don't know if I'm supposed to like
take the pawn and I just I'll just like
all right most coming at me with
something
I feel like mo would want me to take the
pawn so I'm gonna do the counter to what
he's thinking I will do and I was just
like I'm just gonna keep running run and
um it you know and I went five and I
don't know if that was a good move or
not but that's exactly how a car plays
chess ready car it was actually the
exact opposite boy once I moved that
pawn I was like yo please don't take the
pawn then you push pawn or push up move
and then I have to retreat my queen and
I'm already behind in development that's
what went on in my head so I was like
thank God you did it then you push the
pawn and I was like perfect let's get
the stone wall going I remember some of
this so I just started pushing up my
pawns I remember the low pyramid
triangle square thingy that I have to do
and then yeah yeah you know something
happens well a problem also is that your
bishops supposed to go on this dark
square in front of your queen and that
pawn kind of prevents it so it really
turns into just something completely
different
hmm ah wait so was that bad of me to
block with the the bishop was I supposed
to block with the night instead no what
she did was actually completely fine
what was supposed to do is take your
pawn on f5 with on passant oh you know
what you know what I thought I thought
mo was baiting me into doing this last
night I was I'm gonna write a book about
it but it's like the fact that it's
called the on passant like a mind game
basically you do on passant you you give
the opponent the option on passant
when you know it's gonna be bad for them
but they want to like it's probably like
I'm like you know fourteen fifty hundred
play like I'm trying to fly
so ice I know that like advanced chess
technique so I do it anyway and then I
get myself in trouble so I thought do IO
moas honestly in my head here I thought
he like planned all this he was trying
to bait me at like every turn but then
it turns out he was just like get like a
loading bar going on and I was like I
thought I thought he's like doing like
these mind games and stuff I moved to I
was already lost man I was very
confusing myself vinod but for me like I
already felt like I was losing from the
start because I just honestly I didn't
feel prepped enough which isn't is just
my fault I should have prepped a little
more honestly and then I should have
known those black first or whatever but
to me what put me on tilt the most was
when I recaptured after my Bishop takes
Bishop I recaptured with the night
the thing that tilted me most was when I
moved my knight forward sometime and
then I moved it back because then I just
well I felt like I lost so much time
because my plan was to move that night
one Forks move forward again instead of
moving it back and then I was gonna get
my other night out to cover that night
square and then I was gonna like yeah I
was gonna do some maneuvers where I
pushed the rook up one and then I you
know yeah I'd like ideas in mind or
something like that
mm-hm I don't often make sensor works
honestly but you know yo and I was play
I was like pretty happy cuz I was like
okay these pawns like his Bishop is kind
of trapped like the Knights can't get
out of the Rick's stuck there I was like
okay so I feel like most pretty lockdown
on the Queen side so I said okay let me
figure out how to like attack your King
and then when you like when you uh yeah
when you didn't really bring pieces to
the other side I was just like okay this
is good like I feel like I can keep keep
this up and then it kind of worked out
yeah I would say one critical moment and
was it you know if you put each six here
to kick this night away before that's
what I was scared of I'm gonna lie yeah
yeah you're trying to go for an attack
and h6 kicks this night nests forces to
go backwards that would probably have
been a good inclusion for you yeah see I
didn't even think about that in my head
I thought too far ahead and what I saw
was I saw him trying to go from mate
with the Queen so that's why I pushed
the other pawn was to block his Queen
from even coming but then in hindsight
obviously pushing the knight is better
because the Queen can't ever come at the
Knights thread and make it stake and
then the deals to get well said
pretty much
[Laughter]
combination words their rates up but but
actually mo in the game though what you
had to try and do just at one point when
you made the mouse slip was because he
should have moved the other night I
think this is your slip right to go back
to moves before nights I was night to D
something and the point is that you try
to push the pawn to c5 and attack the
pawns no signer oh I see that makes
sense yeah and get my piece out try to
get my Bishop out as well right that was
that was the one opportunity you had
after that I mean is a pretty pretty
rough game but only there was only one
other point later which I was cursed
about which was if you saw his Queen c7
idea if you go yeah it's like where I
try to put my Queen there to look for
mate with my rook on the back oh yeah I
thought you're gonna try that too I was
like his Queen just blocks right and
then it's a trade of Queens and I'm
still losing right right exactly that's
why that's why I thought that's why I
thought I would have to do so again
Queen Bach was the best yeah okay yeah
probably most likely it was yeah but
basically White's winning because black
has pieces that are on the original
squares the rook and the bishop
specifically it's just like no
development can't believe I played
back-to-back games with 10% accuracy
whereas they're really yeah literally
10% back to back and I don't think I've
ever played a chess game on trust calm
where I'd look less than 30% like legit
I don't know something hey boy you bring
out the worst and mo and yet this is
what you did you in the second game by
the way so boy did you realize that you
could have won a night very hey yeah I
did right after I did like as I was
letting go my as I was letting go of my
piece I was like cuz something felt off
in my head I was like I was like okay
this is dude mo is mind gaming he
message me last night he's like bro like
play your Sicilian drag him I got you
downloaded like you got me and I was
just like I was like okay like you know
I will just see what happens and I was
like okay he's he's like planned this
out to the tee I was like maybe is
tilted but something definitely felt off
here when I let go of my knight I think
I was like God I have missed the hanging
night but yeah I realized right after to
once I move on I was like oh wrong
Bishop and that wasn't helpful
and once Boise to take I was like and go
where in the game it's winnable three
moves later I blunder another piece I'm
like okay give them better wait I
thought you might have mouse lit when
you took like night or yeah we can get
there later but I was like a little
confused but I mean it was it was good
night be something later yeah yeah yeah
I was like okay this is crazy
right so I was gonna ask a question
about that so like yeah so at this point
you were obviously in bad shape was this
was this your way of channeling your
inner inner Tyler or something I was
gone till I knew game was over and I was
like either resigned here or I try to
make the game less confusing and hard
frame as possible to try to squeeze out
a win I even did the math in my head and
I'm like if I take Bishop takes then I
go with Queen to take and then his Queen
takes my bishop and it's already still
lost I can't win the Bishop back but
then his rips are connected the knight
moves I already knew his lost but I had
to try something I think at that point
like I felt lost and I knew the game was
over if I just kept going on boys a
strong player and I just try to do
something I went for broke and that was
running way down in work no I I it was
definitely confusing but I was like hmm
I'm pretty sure I just take the bishop
with check and then yeah I did I did I
did respect the the crazy flush like
Babli combo you try to try something
honestly I asked the card in streaming
we confirm that you're asking you're
from New York yeah because I am from New
York you talk super fast so I was like
this guy is this from New York I know a
hundred percent and I also thought your
username ellos dad was a joke about
Carmelo Anthony but it turns out we
don't like Carmelo around these parts
you know I'm with you mode do you think
do you think New York more woulda beat
me in this match the way I play if I
woke up on the same side of the bed I
woke up today yeah but hey I wish you
love the boy regardless in the rest of
the games we're gonna face you're facing
box box reports of three and then it's
either hutch Popov plot their name free
regardless hey boy congratulations
I wouldn't get hey I took out I check
out the biggest Dark Horse dude now I
believe in you men hey and um okay I was
gonna say can we all sing modred a but I
don't know if that's too cringe but
happy birthday man the big the big 21
we're gonna we're gonna celebrate when I
see you man
Carell Thank You Man appreciate that
well thank you everyone thank you for
the games yeah thanks guys thank you
thank you thank you for having me thank
you for the pop champs event I really
enjoyed it may there's no chance if you
happy bird
[Music]
I'm not sure if I should laugh because
it's cringe or if I should cry cuz it's
sweet I'm honestly kind of in the verge
of boaters coming out down my eyes but I
appreciate it guys thank you again thank
for the birthday wishes thank you for
everything and yeah I had a great time
at the park champs event and I wish you
guys the rest best of luck in the future
with the ready thanks mom thank you
[Music]